y en directo a Vamos hasta Panamá para
discutir con nuestro corresponsal Óscar
zulbarán la situación migratoria en ese
país porque solo en lo que va de 2022 la
cifra de personas que atravesó la selva
del Darién fronteriza con Colombia llegó
a más de 158.000 el número sobrepasa a
las 133.000 registradas el año pasado y
solo Durante los primeros tres días de
octubre ya se contabilizaban más de
7.000 migrantes Oscar muy buenas noches
cuéntenos A qué se debe este incremento
en el flujo de migrantes y cuáles son
los principales peligros a los que se
enfrentan en la selva
menos de dos semanas han transcurrido
desde que se igualó la cifra de récord
de migrantes que cruzaron darían en 2021
Y desde ese momento hasta ahora el
número ha aumentado en más de 25.000 es
decir alrededor de 160.000 personas han
llegado a Panamá a través de la selva
Panamá es un país de tránsito según las
autoridades mucho menos del 1% de esas
personas deciden quedarse en el país el
interés primario es llegar a los Estados
Unidos el número de venezolanos ha sido
creciente en lo que va de año pero de
acuerdo a la información que recopila
Panamá de los propios migrantes a su
llegada al istmo no vienen solo de
Venezuela vienen de Colombia Ecuador de
Perú de países donde ya habían
permanecido durante un tiempo sobre el
riesgo que enfrentan en primer lugar
exponerse a una selva virgen que no
tiene ningún tipo de condición amigable
para el tránsito de personas poner en
riesgo la salud ya sea por la picadura
de un animal o por la exigencia del
recorrido por la deshidratación a la que
se pueden someter las personas Pero hay
otros factores que también hacen aún más
peligroso este recorrido y son las
bandas criminales que operan en parte de
esta zona y que han sometido y atacado a
migrantes
Óscar es que el gobierno dijo que no
podía asumir solo esta responsabilidad
que necesita ayuda ahora qué medidas
está tomando Panamá para atender la
situación
en este tema de las medidas que lleva a
cabo el gobierno panameño vale la pena
destacar que son varias cosas que vuelve
estabilidad de migrantes una parte es la
recepción en poblaciones pequeñas de
alrededor de 200 personas que en este
momento están recibiendo al menos estas
últimas semanas dos mil personas Al Día
eso impacta directamente en los
servicios de salud en los servicios
sanitarios el puesto de recepción
migratoria en San Vicente en Darién
también ha visto su capacidad rebasada
el tema de los menores de edad más de
20.000 han atravesado la selva este año
las autoridades panameñas han informado
que una parte importante llega sin sus
padres entonces toca tratar de coordinar
el reencuentro con sus familiares en sus
países de origen el despliegue de
funcionarios de seguridad de servicio
nacional de fronteras en estas zonas
zonas en las que no se logra suficiente
cobertura debido a esas mismas
dificultades para su acceso Así mismo
las denuncias sobre robos o violaciones
es decir hay presencia de las
autoridades panameñas de organizaciones
internacionales se recopila información
Se atiende a los migrantes no podemos
calificar como es esa atención Pero lo
que sí han pedido las autoridades
panameñas a las colombianas es que
pongan atención los sitios donde parten
los migrantes para atravesar la selva y
que se haga un levantamiento completo de
información que incluya no sólo números
sino también temas como edad género y
las condiciones de estas personas